the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so all right so this is a two three
three so as you can see every node has
so the two three is either two children
or three children every node can have
either one key or two keys and the
correlation is that every forever so if
there are n keys in a node it has n plus
1 children so the way that works is well
in the same that's similar to binary
search trees right so if you have value
here the two children surrounding it so
this side is less the side is more so
it's essentially in sorted order going
in an inorder traversal
so let's left she'll route right gel so
in order it's sorted so generally a bee
tree will have some nodes so let's say n
and n plus 1 children and if you take
anything in the middle look at the two
children all the keys in this subtree
are smaller than the key here and all
the see trees keys in this up to your
large in the key here so that's the
general node okay so before we go into
more details of the properties and
everything so the question is why use B
trees so let's like if we do a quick
depth analysis we can see that the depth
is still log n right is that clear to
everyone sort of why the depth is log n
because you have branching this will be
distant like in binary search trees in
fact you're more branching but in any
case depth is to log in but why use B
trees over binary search trees any
another reason why I would prefer to use
B trees or not so like all the
operations to log in any guesses
okay well okay the reason is well memory
hierarchy so normally in algorithms we
just assume that the computer has access
to like memory and you can just pick up
things from disk and constant time and
do your operations with it and you don't
worry about caches and everything but
that's not how computers work right so
in a computer we have so those if you
have taken like some computer
architecture class example for something
you will know so that hierarchy so
that's a CPU so let's draw it somewhere
so you have your CPU and near your CPU
have some registers you have your caches
l1 l2 l3 whatever you have your RAM you
have disk after that so this cuz its
lowest any of your battery your cloud
whatever like each level your memory
size grows and your access time grows as
well so in the basic memory hierarchy
model we have just two levels of
hierarchy let's say so you have cache
connected by a high bandwidth channel to
the CPU and you have a low bad news
channel to disk so the difference is so
essentially you can consider the cache
drill like into the speed - just like
you whatever you can take it you don't
have any costs for bringing in stuff
from cache so but it's finite size so a
cache works is it has a bunch of words
this is a finite finite number of words
so H each word has size size B and let's
say you have m words however hard disk
is just let's say infinite memory but it
has some some cost associated to
accessing things okay also when you
access things on hard disk you copy them
into cash and you copy a block of size B
you take it up from the hard disk and
you try like you take a block and you
put it into cash and you have to get rid
of something because it's finite so what
do you want to do is you want to utilize
those that that B block efficiently you
just want to like bring a B block every
time you want to access a new node in a
binary search tree like normal
operations are what you started the
route go to a node so
but that's not very easily correlated
with this right so if you want to
utilize the entire block you would want
something like a block we chart up goes
down the tree but that's but that's not
how mana tree is a story my entries are
stored this way so that's the nice thing
or B Street B trees so since you can
make so this is just a two three tree
this is not a general Beecher general B
tree will have a bunch of nodes and we
will come to that number but generally
you want to make that number of nodes
something like the cash
what is the cash the word size in the
cash so once you do that you can get an
entire load from disk like work on that
and then like get another internal so
like your height is reduced and you can
do your operations much quicker because
you don't are not accessing accessing
disk every time you're going down the
level
I mean you are actually you are
accessing disk every time you go down a
level but you're get like you're
utilizing the whole block when you're
accessing disk good sort of make sense
okay so let's write down the
specifications for a B for B trees now
all right so some number of children
so okay first of all a b-tree has
something called
a branching factor so in the two three
three the branching factor is two so
what that means it simply it just bounce
the number of children so number of
children has to be greater than equal to
two other than the root node the root
node can have less than D children it's
fine
also it's upper bounded by 2b plus 1/2 B
notice that this is a strict upper bound
so you can have at most two B minus 1
keys and children from a node also
remember that the number of keys the
number of keys is one mile is just one
less than the number of children
therefore these are equality that's
that's not raise their view these
inequalities just get reduced by one so
you want my fun you have to be minus one
so number of keys can be between B minus
1 and 2 B minus 2 the rationale for that
will become clear of no be the badging
so be B is the branching factor so that
is the number of children like it's not
a number of children but it's it's a
bound of the number of children so like
in the 2 3 3 so B is equal to 2 and this
is a 2 3 3 so the 2 refers to you can
have either 2 children or you can have 3
children
so and so they here so the upper bound
in children is 2b minus 1 right to D
minus 1 is equal to 3 so can I head out
at 2 or 3 children
if correspondingly you can have either
one or two keys and the node make sense
oh okay it's coming back to this so the
root does not have a lower bound the
root can have one child in any tree so
you have a be equal to 5/3 that would
consider one channel sorry not one child
one key element two children all right
it's good also it's completely balanced
so all the leaves
are the same depth so like you can still
consider it
so although so you know you can't have
like a dangling dangling note here this
is not love you have to have a leaf you
have to have something going down and
everything ends at the same level all
right so that's thing so also the Leafs
obviously don't have children so the
this this condition is violated by the
leaf alright so that's the basic
structure will be tree now so the first
operation will consider on B trees is
searching so that should be relatively
straightforward right so remember how
the searching is done in the binary
search tree you bring in a value X
compared to the key let's say X is less
than K you go down this flap map let's
say X is greater than K you go down this
path so similarly in the B tree so let's
say you bring in a value let's say you
are looking for 20 so you bring in 20
compare it to this 20 is less than 30 so
go down here now you have three values
sorry two values so where does 20 fit in
here not here not here it fits here okay
go around this tree you find 20 that's
it so in general you bring in a KPK you
look at this node and you go to all the
values so something I forgot to mention
so which should be clear all about all
the keys in a node they're sorted one up
the other so your values go like this so
they're increasing in this way look
sighs okay so so bring in a key look at
all the keys in the node you're looking
at pick the one pick the place where K
fits in I unless it's already in the
node then you're done if I we found it
otherwise let's say the K fits in
between these two these two guys so you
go down this child and continue so
searching is log n similar to bsts
okay okay so searching is not very
interesting so next is insertion so
insertion look a little more it's just
interesting when searching so what you
do an insertion is you oh okay well I
guess we'll start start around again
okay well should we move back the
original room okay let's let's do that
so before we resume does anyone have any
questions about the structure of B trees
we're asked to that quite a lot quite
fast so about how B trees are structured
everyone good with that okay also any
questions about searching in a B tree or
a BST all right good yep so one value to
children so like so like whatever is so
you have some node in the B tree and
whatever is below it is split into parts
by the elements so if you have n
elements it splits it up into n plus 1
segments okay all right
No well you will see when we do
insertion and deletion why that's not
necessary but like essentially like off
you can consider that it's an invariant
and all we have to do is preserve that
invariant so the root can has to it has
to have less than two it's nice to have
the upper bound but it doesn't need have
lower with though the whole interview
double the cache size there's something
something like that so you probably want
to be to be about your cache size so you
can get the whole block in one go I
don't
I've never implemented to be free so I I
don't know how it's actually done in
practice but that is the reason so I'm
assuming it's something to do with the
cache line well it's not a child fighter
it's a child of this node so this node
has two elements so it's being divided
dividing the interval up into three set
three parts so if the child if it's in
between 10 and 17 is the pointer sorry I
know it has three children so don't
think of every key as a node think of
like the whole the whole unit has a node
okay so like it's not a so in the binary
search tree have one element but here
every node has multiple elements that's
the point of it okay anyone else okay
let's start with searching so sleep this
year
oh well
well you have the formulas up there so
that's good okay so insertion let's
start answer you already did searching
okay
so insertion is you bring a new key K
anyone inserted into the tree so what's
the problem that could happen you can
find the location where you want to
insert it just like searching right you
just go down the tree and find where it
should be placed but once you do place
it you have a problem what is the
problem the problem is that one of your
notes will become over four and that's
not what you are
whatever is it'll overflow and that's
not what you want so you want some you
want some way so you can manage this how
do you manage that so and this lovely
prop here which like now hope to
demonstrate that's all okay so so here
we have B before so let's first figure
out a number of keys so what is the
minimum number of keys anyone for B
equal to 4/3 so what is the maximum
number of keys 3 4 into 2 minus 2
correct 44 but it's not 7 there's a
strictly less than sign somewhere yes
and you'll see why it's not 7 another Oh
I prepared with me okay all right so as
you can see one two three four five six
seven so some insertion happen other is
the writing clear and everyone read the
numbers good okay 49 looks a little
skewed anyway essentially these are all
sorted this is the parent node doesn't
matter what's over here all that matters
is 8 56 and that and whatever is in
between okay now so what we do when we
have an overflow node is what something
let's call a split operation so split
and there's something we just got to
merge which we'll come to later when
you're doing deletion but now so split
is very very intuitively it splits the
node into two parts so what is does is
funny orbital node the number of
elements here is 1/2 B minus 1 which is
just 1 over the max so what you do is
you take the middle element and remove
it and now you've split the node into
two parts observe that there are 3 3 & 3
here which is perfect and now what you
do with the middle node so now we give
our actually to start with the structure
of the tree because there was one
pointer going in there's one child and I
have two children so somehow you need to
adjust the parent node because the
parent node had only one child
well at least they the rather children
off to the side but here it only had
only one child and now it's wet apart so
you do something very simple you just
insert this guy in here and then you say
oh this point here and this point should
make sense
I'm gonna get rid of these two okay so
and they even convince yourself that
this preserves all the nice properties
so your children are being I have nicely
fallen back into their interval your
sequence is completely correct because
this was the middle element of this so
this divides this interval properly this
is also between eight and fifty six
because this was in this node so all the
properties but there's one property that
is a problem so you have just increased
the size of the parent node by one so
now it's possible that the parent node
has overflowed what do you do you split
it again and it fit again and if you if
any point you're fine
you look you look at the parent node and
go okay that's fine that's that's in the
range but every time it overflows you
can keep going and how many times can I
do this you can do this all the way up
to the root and when you reach the root
you either it's fine or the root is too
big its reach to to be minus 1 and then
you split the root and you get one
single turnover up there so that in
answer to your question that is why you
need that property in some sense not a
very convincing argument sort of family
but anything let's actually do an
insertion in this tree behavior so we
are going to insert 16 ok
so 16 comes in here it's less than 30
goes the left is between 10 and 17 goes
in the middle 16 and it's greater than
14 so we add 16 here
oh wait no all right okay no that's good
yeah all right
that seems good all the property is fine
this is still has two elements which is
the maximum but it's good it doesn't
overflow okay
let's insert something else let's insert
2 so 2 goes to 30 Goes Down Goes Down
and we have a problem because two has
overflowed this node so we split and the
way we split is we take the middle
element so we split the node here good
and three goes up to the parent so 3
goes here and all good except for the
parent is overflowed so what we do with
the parent we split the parent again
let's write it down the middle the 10
goes up so ok let's get rid of this so
now that is to the turn the 10 goes up
here and you're good it's a bit
cluttered so let me reposition the 17
okay those two operations make sense
questions yeah so just pick just pick
the first of all okay if the way we are
doing it when you know to the over
function inserting only one thing at a
time right so if you know it is
overflowing it will be 2 t minus 1 which
is an odd number always there are there
might be a case where you get an even
number if you do something weird maybe
you have it like there are like
different ways to do B trees but if it
does you can probably pick the one like
any either of them and then this little
symbol I'm not sure about that I'll look
into it but in general if you're doing
it this way law is always on so you know
how to worry about that and anything
else yeah so what you do is that will
rub two children one one element and
teacher which is fine because we didn't
put the restriction on it yeah that's
good how we doing on time okay you have
some time all right let's jump into
division unless anyone else has
questions so so oh yeah oh that's good
thank you so you are going down to the
Leafs at most like at most of the Leafs
ones and you're going back up one so
it's like log n let's log in and you're
good okay huh let's do deletion
okay so deletion is more complicated so
the reason is we clear so what the
problem and deletion will be remove a
node and a node is now under full so
it's it has less than B minus 1 keys in
it suddenly so let's turn this around
there yeah okay good so again be equal
before this node is the problem only two
things in it
so what do we do okay so before we go
into that let's make this assumption
that okay so there are two steps to
deletion the first step is making the
deletion out of leaf how do you do that
the way you make a deletion of the leaf
is let's say you have have a key you
come down you're binding you know B tree
and you're at a node now this node you
guys oh this key needs to be doing here
but it's not the leaf so what do you do
so you essentially what you do is you
look at these two sub trees right so it
might have only one sub U is at the end
it'll have only one actually no that's
not good no no way ignore that if it's
not a leaf it has two sub trees
so either take the rightmost element in
this sub tree which is a leaf because
you can always keep going down right
right right right till you get your leaf
or the leftmost element in this sub tree
so that is just the next element after
this guy so you delete this and you
bring this up to here we'll do an
example of this anyway a bit clearer but
you so you take either the rightmost
element left subtree or left most of
them into the right subtree and bring it
up here so you sort of like move the
deletion to the leaf and now it's easier
to deal with so we work on for that
other just just note that this is not
what is done in the rest you so let's
sort this algorithm for deletion i think
is not done in recitation notes this is
a different thing which i'll send out a
link for later but i believe it works
because i got from them a penny
reference okay so once you go to the
leaf
so now let's let's look at this so this
is a node that is under full and you
want to fix it so how do you fix it so
what do you do is you look at its
sibling so in this case it has one
sibling it can have up to two siblings
you can have left or the right okay so
what you do is you look at a sibling and
this sibling is actually one over the
minimum and if it's one over the minimum
then your then your it's really easy all
you have to do is take the leftmost
thing here or sibling is on this I take
a rightmost thing here you and look and
look at its parent so you bring the
parent down and you move the sibling up
and there we go
so you basically like track so you are
rotating the thing into place so you
move the parent down into the wonderful
node and you replace the parent by the
leftmost thing here everyone see where
that preserves everything okay and also
okay yeah and the child is also shifted
make sure you see that so like the child
which was in this subtree is now in this
sub tree all right but then you can have
the situation where you don't have a
nice sibling to take care of your
problems so in lieu take this scenario
this sibling is that barely full it has
three things in it then it can't donate
anything to you
so what do you do in that case so then
you do something which is a parallel of
the split operation you do a merge
so what do you have so here you have B
minus two and here you have B minus one
and you get to B minus three well you
get another element you also take the
parent so how you do the more journeys
going to show you the merge first so the
way you do it is you move the parent
down and you merge these two seams okay
so you move parent lowdown merge these
two and well now this control and this
points in to the new node
sort of clear what's going on questions
well so you have discrete yeah exactly
so you have decreased sized apparent so
it might not be under four so you drop
propagate anything else so there are two
cases right so either you have a sibling
which has extra nodes to donate to you
or you don't if you don't then you have
to do this if you know that is moving it
down to the leaf once you move the
galician down to the leaf so here we
have something now and now you move it
all the way back up okay so there are
two cases the rotation so okay let's do
an example that will make it clear how
are you doing on time all right okay so
we are going to delete 38 38 is gone
so but we want to move it down to the
leaf so let's take an element let's say
we take 41 so we take 41 and move it up
here 41 is the leftmost thing in the
right subtree so this vacancy doesn't
really affect anything because this node
is still has the right number of things
because it still got one thing in it
which is good okay fine
this is now 40 years 48 okay let's say
we now do it 41 so 41 is gone so now
that 41 is gone
what do you replace 40 what do you look
good place is blank spot with
either this or this right doesn't matter
so let's just do this one for
consistency so you have 48 here and now
you're a problem because you have a
blank box okay so can you rotate yes no
no right because subbing has is barely
full so what can you do so well you
merge and how do you merge you move the
party it down and you combine everything
so you have so this is this is kind of
hard to understand but this is like a
zero element node look so you when you
merge your 32 48 oh nothing so it's just
very good 48 so what do you do is so
this seems weird but this is just
another empty node you just like
propagated the emptiness upwards now you
take this empty node and you look for
its siblings again its sibling is well
it's almost barely full so what do you
do again you bring the 30 down and you
merge this so let's do that so
thirty comes down and there we go all
the problem looks fine does that create
good questions about the operation I'm
sure was not clear but anything I tends
okay let's let's do a deletion where we
can actually do a rotation so let's go
ahead and delete 20 so you do your
searching go down the tree you find the
21 do we good it's gone now
okay so you're left with just the action
of the government they do another one so
this doesn't do anything your little ass
the 20 and you'll have to pay for that
so now we doing the 24 now that you got
rid of 24 you have a blank box here now
but it's sibling is not barely full it
has something to do Nate so what'll it
do so anyone which which which elements
are going to rotate 16 17 right okay
oh so 16 goes up 17 goes down and you're
done you're consistent again
okay so that was deletion so those those
are the two cases for deletion does that
make sense everyone any questions okay
so that's all the topics we were
supposed to cover today any questions
about any of the operations any of the
other topics lecture or anything